as some of you may know the anti-choice
Republicans in the United States have
been pushing all sorts of bills that
would qualify a fetus as a person and
thus it would open up the door to a lot
of what I would consider really
problematic possibilities like for
example prison for mothers who have
abortions prison for doctors who perform
abortions murder charges for abortions
manslaughter charges for miscarriage I
mean really ugly backwards stuff and one
of those states is Alabama and it has
just gotten really disturbing they're
actually related to a story that's not
directly about abortion but we need to
sort of think critically about what the
implications here are now before I get
to the full story this is the type of
story that I believe is important to
cover but this story is going to be
demonetised by YouTube we've been
talking about these issues on YouTube
YouTube's an important revenue source
for us but these are important stories
for us to cover so consider supporting
us with a membership at david pakman.com
so that we can just keep covering the
stories that deserve coverage and not
have to worry about how it's going to
impact the show's revenue so the story
is as follows a 27 year old Alabama
woman was shot in the stomach while
pregnant and she was shot by another
woman and being shot in the stomach
resulted in a miscarriage she is now
being charged with manslaughter for that
miscarriage which of course is connected
to her being the victim of a shooting so
there's a whole bunch of details here
that can be discussed one is that the
fight that led to the shooting was
between the pregnant woman marché Jones
and another woman who were fighting over
the fetuses father the shooter evany
Jamison was charged with manslaughter
initially and not indicted by a grand
jury
so that charge was dismissed now Jones
has been indicted on a manslaughter
charge the argument being made by police
in Pleasant Grove Alabama is that the
mother instigated the argument with the
other woman that the victim here is the
unborn fetus and were it not for the
instigation of the mother that none of
this would have happened
therefore the mother should be charged
with manslaughter now you might
this often say Alabama this wouldn't
happen anywhere else that's not true
there are 38 states that classify
fetuses as victims in homicide or
assault and the truth is that sometimes
that does make sense okay if a burglary
gone wrong leads to a burglar shooting a
pregnant woman and both the woman and
the fetus die the fact that there was
the potential for life there and that to
actual or potential lives were cut short
should be considered by the law the
problem is that in places like Alabama
it's being applied in really ridiculous
ways that truly stretch credulity and
require I mean I I'd call it imagination
and in a sense are criminalizing of
pregnancy and the reason that lots of
anti-choice activists love this
indictment is they understand they
understand the long game and they see
that prosecution for an abortion is only
half a step beyond what we're seeing in
Alabama right now so understand that in
reading the details of the situation it
may well be that the mother instigated
or escalated or perpetuated this
disagreement with the other woman but
escalating the fight or the argument
doesn't excuse the person with the gun
who decided to do the shooting which led
to the death of the fetus and it will be
used by the anti-choice right to push
for changes that would open the door to
and encourage criminal charges for women
having abortions so there's a lot of
disagreement on this one even including
within some enclaves of the left so I
want to hear from you about it what do
you think about this research the
details of the story first and then let
me know what you think today's sponsor
is Skillshare and I'm excited to tell
you that everybody in our audience is
getting two entire months of free access
to Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skills fairs the
site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing
Photoshop managing a small business
almost an endless list and whether
you're trying to get ahead in your
career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]